members of Calgary's Ukrainian Community
together in a show of support anxiously
waiting to see how such a Brazen
challenge of the Russian president will
impact their Homeland we want our
country back we want it to be free we
wanted to be liberated a day after an
11th Hour Deal saw Evgeni pragosian
abort his Mutiny attempt prime minister
Justin Trudeau spoke with the Ukrainian
president on Twitter Vladimir zielinski
said he spoke about the current
situation on the battlefield and shared
Ukraine's assessment of the attempted
coup in Russia there are lots of
unanswered questions including the
questions of what happens to pagosian's
forces did there remain in uh in Ukraine
I mean we saw the extraordinary image of
these forces coming out of Ukraine and
going into Russia yeah just yesterday
Landing in Iceland Sunday Trudeau is
scheduled to meet with Nordic leaders
for a two-day Summit the best course of
action I think is to to wait and see
really we don't want to play favorites
the you know in any kind of conflict
between Putin pregosian or any other
kind of Russian warlord uh you know
there are no good guys in this situation
well the uprising appeared to take
Moscow by surprise reports suggest U.S
intelligence officials had been aware of
pagosian's plans to challenge the
Russian leadership for some time and
this really is fundamentally an internal
matter for the Russians we're seeing it
we're seeing it unfold again we saw the
rising tensions over over a couple over
several months that led to this but
exactly where this goes
um we don't know millions of ukrainians
forced from their homes by War will be
watching closely to find out
[Music]
Heather urich's West Global News Calgary